what do you know about filmmaking that
you wish you knew before and again i
realize that's you know that's like a
typical job interview question
but there's a lot of weight to it and
sure i mean i i think
the really the biggest thing that i
have learned is just the
secrets of distribution the actual
filmmaking part
you you just you just need to make
mistakes in order to grow
so you know with the actual creativity
and putting it together
and not planning and seeing how that
turns out and then doing a little more
planning and seeing how that
turns out it's all it really is all part
of the process and it's
it's something that everyone i think
needs to go through
even if they try not to they're going to
make mistakes it's necessary
uh to make the best movie the only like
cold
hard facts that you can actually learn
is pretty much
now that i made the movie how do i get
it out there and
that's also always evolving and changing
so
you know the the means of distribution
seven years ago is completely different
than what it is now uh so you have to
stay on top of that but
sort of just understanding what your
film's value is
and what is possible is the the
biggest thing that i've learned over the
past few years
how do you know what the value is i
guess what i mean by
value is sort of
having the confidence to to know that
there is an audience for your film
if you if you you know put in this
some if you put a year's worth of time
and effort into making a movie
there is going to be an audience for it
somewhere you know there is there is
a lot of people in this world and and a
lot of people have tvs and computers and
nowadays that's all you need to share
content
and even if you can't get distribution
you can self-distribute now like i i
wasn't able to do that
10 years ago and if i did then i just
didn't know about it
now it's so much more user-friendly and
you can get your movie on amazon prime
like that with with their amazon
video direct service um
so it really it's it's inspiring
and it gives me hope knowing that the
success of your film relies entirely on
the work that you put into it
can you share with us the process of
getting your movie on amazon prime
yeah so it's a service called amazon
video direct
and i i did i set this up about a year
and a half ago for our first movie
and you really just follow the
instructions you upload your file
you upload your subtitles and
after it's approved you literally just
link it to your you know bank account
and you have all the analytics and
everything and
it's on you to market and promote your
movie and you can choose whether or not
you want to put it on prime so
prime users can stream it for free or
you can set it you know to just for
rental and purchase um but
i think vimeo also offers a service
where you can do that so if you're
interested in self distribution
vimeo and amazon i think are the best
platforms to do that on right now
and what type of video file is it oh i
i don't remember exactly what kind of
video file they
require probably like an mp4 or
h.264 um 4k
file ideally i i think you can put
anything
any any format you want i believe
um it doesn't necessarily have to be 4k
and i'm not like a master at the self
distribution i've only done it once
so uh don't quote me on this but
but it's pretty simple and amazon
definitely has instructions on how to do
it properly
with the text of the the subtitles is it
a text file or
how are you i upload it i think so i
think it is a
text file i'm not i'm not sure i i think
i remember
actually going using youtube
i uploaded the movie to youtube it
youtube has an algorithm that
automatically scans every word
and then i copied all of that text from
the youtube
platform and then put that into the
amazon platform
and then i just had to sort of you know
edit some of like the spacing and
alignments just to
match but there there are ways to figure
it out and google has been very good to
me in helping me through that process
so yeah but but yeah i think it was like
about a year and a half since i went
through that
and i think i did the entire
uh i set up the entire self-distribution
thing in about
a day or two really the hardest part was
just
really just uh waiting for it to upload
and then get approved by
by amazon um and and there's also a good
chance that the entire
uh means of uploading has changed since
then
i've been getting emails about changes
to their service
and layout and i don't really check it
that often i kind of figured you know
50 north is certainly a movie that i
made a long time ago i don't intend on
searching for a whole new distribution
deal or anything so
i figured i'd just you know put it up on
amazon and
let it live there how do you think
teaching others on youtube has helped
you
to become a better filmmaker i think
it's
sort of forced me to come up with the
most efficient
method of doing certain things that
i can then just apply to my own
filmmaking and do it that much faster
whereas
ordinarily i'd have to you know think
about how am i going to do this effect
or
you know i i need to experiment in
premiere
after effects trying to figure out a
certain you know effects that i'm trying
to do
doing these tutorials i research the
hell out of a certain
topic and then i just streamline it so
that i can
say it as succinctly and easy to
understand
as possible so on some level it's also
helped with communication
is you know i think if you can show
other people how to do something
it helps you do it even better
and how has either receiving um
reaction videos or getting comments
shaped your idea of audience feedback
if it has i'm sure it's it's happened
more subconsciously i
i i try to read as many comments as i
can i'm sure a lot of people are like
don't read the comments that's a bad
idea but
i like reading them even even if they're
not great um
i i'm i'm pretty honest with myself and
i i
have a feeling you know about the type
of content i'm putting out and
you know where it stands and with
everything else and
i i see tr some truth in
some of the mean comments sometimes i'm
like they're just me and that's
ridiculous
and i love the support and i love you
know uh
reading all the the positivity and and
most most of the comments are are good
like there's
there's not too many people that are
just you know all over
everything
and uh uh hating what we do and
if if they are then it's just it's not
for them and that's okay
yeah i love it when people share about
their process or their life and
you're reading about someone you know
overseas and what they do
and to me that those are my favorite
comments just
just to hear other people's process and
absolutely
i i just released our first making of
video on our channel just uh yesterday
actually
um i i mean i'm hugely inspired by david
f sandberg and i love that he does that
on his channel
so you know i'm thinking well i love
that he does that
i should do that for people that are
watching our short films
uh you know why would i deprive them if
for anyone that wants to see it
here it is so you know i put that
together and it's
it's uh it's cool
you